let's talk about Andrea Mitchell this
one is really incredible Andrea Mitchell
has been a journalist on NBC and MSNBC
and a bunch of other places she's not
Meet the Press all the time
she goes she gets major major interviews
she goes to all of the presidential
debates etc etc she is thought of as a
mainstream non-partisan journalist okay
here she is sitting down with Kamala
Harris talking about what Ron DeSantis
is doing with these AP courses now
listen to the way she frames the
question now you just have to think
before we show you the clip does Andrea
Mitchell have no idea what she's talking
about or is she a paid activist to push
a certain point of view and then you
just you're saying it's a Kamala who has
about two neurons firing so a lot of
dribble out of her go what does Governor
Ron DeSantis not know a black about
black history and the black experience
when he says that
slavery and the aftermath of slavery
should not be taught to Florida school
children I don't know what he knows and
what he doesn't know but I know this
any push to censor
America's teachers
and tell them what they should be
teaching in the best interest of our
children
in
in partnership with the parents of
America is I think
um wrong-headed
the people who know our children best
are their parents and their teachers in
terms of the time they spend and the
investment they've placed in the brains
and capacity
of our children who are our nation's
future and
it should not be some politician
saying what should be taught in our
classrooms
it's so incredible Kamala is just an
idiot so I don't even know that I can
deal with her man I'm fired up on this
Monday morning
yeah it's because I'm running an
infirmary all weekend I haven't spoke to
an adult in a while it's good to see you
guys look Kamal is just an idiot
everything she says there if you
believed any of that Kamala you would be
for school choice right it shouldn't be
politicians who tell kids what to do
except you and the Democrats are the
ones that want all of the kids going to
public schools so that they can be
brainwashed by your teachers unions and
everything else so she's just a Mindless
buffoon let's just move her aside Andrea
Mitchell what an insane what an insane
way of framing this what does Ron
DeSantis not know about the black
experience something to that effect what
a crazy way why does he not want slavery
and the aftermath of Slavery to be
taught it is a complete lie so you must
understand these people that work at NBC
News the the segment producer you have
to be fired somebody has to be fired if
we're to believe that any of this means
anything now I get it there again
they're not in the business of Truth
they are not in the business of anything
honest they are in the business of
propaganda so when I say that they
should be fired I understand no one's
going to be fired but Andrea Mitchell
should be shamed everywhere she goes
because again either she's an idiot so
she's asking questions of which she
knows nothing about or she is paid the
segment producer and the producer above
that and the EP is a whole machine at
NBC news they are literally paying them
to lie so that Kamala Harris who's a
can lie in her response but they
launder the lies together as I often say
[Music]
foreign